[Musique]
c'est dans ce paysage bucolique des
plateaux du doubs que l'on élève la
fameuse race de vache la montbéliarde
reconnaissable à sa robe blanche attache
au rouge c'est la vraie race
montbéliarde la vraie race montbéliarde
c'est presque sélectionnés pour en faire
une vraie race de matières ainsi avec
son bon lait provenant de nos pâturages
d'herbe grasse nous mettons aucun
produit chimique de façon à ce que le le
produit qui en découlent soient le plus
naturel possible est une race de vache
de production laitière spécifique
spécialement pour la fabrication du
fromage qui est le fromage traditionnel
du pays qu'elles comptaient pour
fabriquer un compte et par lui même il
faut 2h30 pour qu'il soit vengé congo
six mois
avec ce comté ont fait la fondue il ya
plusieurs façons de la confectionner
voici une fondue comtoise vous mettez du
comté natal du bon ben je recommence une
mode je fonde le caquelon avec booth
d'oeil tout au tout pour empêcher de
coller pour ne pas te le comte écoles et
après que de peu de vin blanc crois tu
poses un plan du bon vin blanc oui nos
meilleurs et vous mettez de la moutarde
j'ai un peu de la tonne ça renforce le
goût qui s'accordent le gac de concret
mettez-vous comme du compte et
uniquement du compte elle met deux
sortes de compter vos préférences de
deux sortes et combien de vous mettez de
côté pour une fondue de vie personnes à
peu près aux mêmes faut compter une
bouteille de vin
toi tu as un pays un kilo de fromage et
ont rappelé fromage donc oui et on remue
tout doucement très doucement mais c'est
vous qui faites toujours la fondue ah
oui ma femme de me passe même pas faire
ça elle aimerait manger
il a dérangé a même assuré paye encore à
l'origine à profit leur origine la
fondue typique aux pays bas des moules
frites en savoie
[Musique]